just like the previous question I'm
going to do the formula first at the
first principle second okay so being
that I'm using the formula in the
formula for the sole focus GP actually
some mysteries has ends in it the very
first thing I ought to probably do to
help me up ears rewrite at me a
different path oh yeah
so alright now using the formula that's
just quite that first which form should
I use
I can go 1-1 again or I can get out of
the N minus 1 what would you use in this
case leave your 1 - right why good
that's right the ratio is smaller than 1
it's not negative audience it feels like
that to them because things are so the
ratio is an issue is what is it okay
let's stop please I'm dying here first
term is equal to we already just decided
that the ratios are fern
now we leave it at this before let's see
if we can apply a different multiple
pressures to work out how many terms are
they here yeah maybe this excuse me let
me try it up without writing it out so
much but trying to apply some logic
right from here 3m right what am i doing
I'm sort of counting down on time right
I'm coming down to an eventually we'll
get four three vamp I'll get through two
three to the power of one
now how many transistors this is n times
but it's still the same it'd be just
like if I were coming up from one two
three four five six seven and okay so
this is intense
now let me skip skip a turn for a second
because then it goes through three two
minus one and it goes down to two three
to the eventually minus n how many tabs
on it from minus 1 to minus 10 it's up
in turn then you go one more time
you see by the way I'm not dividing it
up fairly I'm trying to move for chunks
or sections where I know exactly time
each other all right what's immediately
after 3 to minus n I'm decreasing right
what's the next term nice ain't much one
they're not going to go home at the end
and choose 3 to the minus
yes how many times these two are
equivalent
okay right I can factor us I could
factor out the 3 - and let me just
before right
they're like you see what I've done
right so the numbers over here here the
key is the same as here they're really
the same kind of length is it yeah I
said I left one out what did I leave out
which tell you know
three two zero four one right where does
it fit you can see it right here sir
sorry I did this only ends I really
shouldn't talking case how many turns
are there 1 2 3 cave
okay now on the bottom one - the ratio
which is so there's always substitution
let's just work this out okay on the top
here I can do something to make this
easy before you write that 1/3 it's
better if I put on the same base is it
because man that can talk to this and so
3 the boats one that's better 1 - 3
develop now the minus 1 will interact
with that multiply so this will become
minus 3 yeah all over what's the
denominator 2/3
okay now that dividing by a fraction
that threes going to taunt the top yes
so that's going to become 3 2 k plus 1
all over 2
happy with that that's a good okay last
minute index laws here what are you
gonna get when you put those two
together
there's K plus 1 here and a minus 3 k
minus 1 here what we get
I'm adding these indices together right
- K - we can we come - 2 K and then the
one in the minus 1 cancel that sums up
I'm all over the student is my answer
ok so there was by a formula right now
let's compare that they're doing it by
first principles what is the first
principle stop it starts up here right
what would I do
x now he's an interesting thing okay
what would we normally add multiply last
time I multiply by - why would you -
because he was the ratio right so here
when they're following the same process
you multiply by their now it's
interesting that you don't work out fine
if you multiply by firm okay we'll get
there okay but I just know a bit
discriminatory I still might
okay so I'm gonna multiply by three now
you like to Center the ratio or is it
because it's the reciprocal right I
actually can use three can you see why
remember a series right the water is
there but I can turn it around backwards
and it's still gonna add up to the same
thing and I really worry about what it
adds up to all right
so therefore if I turn it around
backwards the ratio is my 30 it's three
okay I subtract the original series
yes which terms will be left over
I'll have this guy he's the spare
there's no equipment that's right all of
these were to get knocked out and then
what's left on the end it's gonna be
this guy he's he's the one who doesn't
get going
that's 2 Sigma so I should just divide
by 2 to get one see and there I am now
last time it looked like they were about
the same amount of work it's not
starting to look so equivalent anymore
is it
especially when you saw how much work it
took to all right there and to be sure
that we knew exactly how he takes away
so I'm just trying to mount the evidence
for why best principles for questions